today's lesson is carrying on from what
we've had a look at over the last week
or so when we think about fractions
decimals and percentages one of the
reasons why we're there's so much time
to think about them is because they come
up constantly and also they come up when
you don't have necessarily access to a
calculator or something like that you've
got to do things in your head now you're
already pretty experienced at this but
we want to make you better and so I'm
gonna give you three quick tips for
doing mental percentages some of which
you'll be familiar with others maybe not
so much then we're gonna have some
practice on it and then depending on how
we go with the time we will play a game
you'll need your device for it but it's
an if
Livan so we'll see how we go okay so
here's for mental percentages my first
tip for you is when you can use
equivalent fractions now we know what
equivalent fractions are every
percentage that you have ever met is a
fraction it's just a fraction over a
hundred right 23 percent would be 23
over one hundred seventy percent seventy
over a hundred but lots of the fractions
you're going to encounter there are nice
convenient equivalent fractions for them
for example if we said 25 percent of
something then your mind should
immediately think oh I have it
equivalent fraction for that that's very
simple right what's the equivalent
fraction for 25 percent I came to talk
you can start off one over four very
good so if I wanted you to find out 25
percent of a thing then take that and
essentially divide by 4 whatever
quantity that you get so 25 percent can
someone give me another example of a
percentage that you know a nice
equivalent fraction of for Jessica 50
percent and the equivalent is someone
else so okay Mary 50% 1 / 2 very good so
you divide by 2 so we'll give you
another percentage that we have it going
for other ways 100 percent so what's the
equivalent fraction for that it's just 1
over 1 so you don't need to do any
calculation could someone give me one
more let's give Marik you've already
given me one yeah go ahead here 20
percent so if I saw 20 percent of a
thing what would be the equivalent
fraction I would should divide by
five very good okay so you get the idea
right when you can spot an equipment
fraction use it very good tip number one
okay tip number two use something which
you've probably met before we haven't
thought about it in this context
significant figures use significant
figures now I'm not going to ask you
just yet but raise your head if you know
uh significant figures are you're like
I've seen this before yes oh very few
hands going up
okay here's now all of you on the right
hand side of your page write down a
number for me let's write down hmm how
about something like this so this is
actually an important number we're going
to tell you what it's important for a
number like this right it's very
detailed if I had a hundred and thirty
one thousand seven hundred two objects
that's very very detailed but sometimes
I just want to get like a ballpark
figure I want to say okay you know what
in the scheme of a hundred and one
thirty one thousand seven hundred and
two objects the two it's not that
important like if I had a hundred and
thirty one thousand seven hundred
objects you'd probably call that about
the same wouldn't you would you say
that's roughly equivalent yeah how about
a hundred and thirty one thousand would
you still say that's roughly equivalent
132 would be a bit closer okay how about
a hundred and thirty thousand would you
still say that's roughly the same number
it depends on what it is isn't it if
you're like if this is a number of
people and I'm in the 1700 - you'd say
that very important that's very
important to me right but I think in
general if for example you saw a hundred
thirty one thousand seven hundred two
grains of sand and 130 thousand grains
of sand would you be able to tell which
is which
probably not right so what we're saying
here is that there are some figures that
are much more significant we might say
these front two right I could write this
as a hundred and thirty thousand and
that would have only two significant
figures in it do you agree does that
make sense and often we say you know
does anyone know what the population of
Australia is at the moment
roughly 25 million now we don't mean
it's exactly 25 million at six years
after the end we are using significant
figures how many significant figures are
there for 25 million just to the 2 and
the 5 right how about when I say there
are roughly this many students in the
school there's really just one
significant figure right you could argue
that it's 20 hundreds but I think we
just see the 2 and that's the part that
matter ok so how does that relate to
percentages well let me give you an
example suppose I asked you to I had
some numbers here prepared I asked you
to calculate this ok now what I'm gonna
ask you to do is to focus just on these
significant figures in these numbers
that you can see in the percentage and
also in this quantity over here why are
the significant figures here it's just
the that's just the 3 isn't it present
and what are the significant figures
here just the one of the five so I'm
just going to put them together okay now
here's how you could really quickly work
out what this is cuz we just focused on
the important part right we should all
go our three times table as well enough
to say 3 times 15 instantly is 45 very
good but what I'm gonna say is this is
just the significant figures right I'm
missing some zeros so it's either 45 or
450 or 4500 one of these is my hearts up
hopefully you can just sort of
instinctively look at that and tell me
which of these three is the answer
what are you marry 45 is that 30% off oh
hold on I got some angry angry responses
how did you work out so quickly that it
was 400 too young
because three times so yeah here go
ahead
okay so you've gone straight to the
actual direct calculation but I noticed
there's a zero here but they're zeros
here as well how could you think this is
mentally right how could you do
intuitively work out which one it is
I'll give you a clue the first one might
help Jessica okay so we're still you
guys are all still doing a calculation
of numbers of zeros right if I I've
given you a nice easy example here if I
have like seven zeros here and eight
zeros here it starts to become more
tricky Leah what do you see okay Leah's
logic there is so important it's the
whole point of things mentally I'm going
to repeat it right 45 out of 1500 this
is a tiny proportion of this group of
people right whereas 4,500 this is well
this is bigger than what we started with
right it's not likely to be that one
this one's right here in the middle and
as Leah said thirty percent it's about a
third does that feel like about a third
of 1,500 to you it it should because it
is about a third of 1,500 it's a bit
less than that isn't it by the way why
is it a bit less have a think yeah yeah
very good what would be closer to a
third what should the percentage be yeah
noise what do you recommend
okay yet really good yeah 33 and lots of
threes actually not a dot percent that
would be exactly a third thirty percent
is just a little bit less than that make
sense so we work out using equivalent
fractions using significant figures one
last tip for you I want to call your
mind back to a word which mrs. Lee and I
actually mentioned a few times when we
learnt at last year in algebra
it's um this word here I gotta make sure
I spelt it wrong
hmm you to you about missing a teen and
I I think I'm missing extra letters
community
that's better it's hard to say it's even
harder to spell when we say that an
operation is commutative commutative
what does that mean about the operation
like addition for example is commuted
does anyone know what that means if you
had for example five plus three that's
equal to three plus five right do you
agree with that those those numbers they
can commute back and forth that's
literally what it means so what that's
talking about is we can change the order
right addition is commutative
what's another operation that's
commutative hey-ya multiplication and
that's important to me because you can
see all along here I'm thinking about
multiplication and division so here's a
really cool where my blue mark oh there
it is Lamine says here's a really cool
sneaky thing right if you're asked to
calculate some percentage let's call it
P like 30 or 25 or something like that
some percentage of some number it just
so happens and I'll let you have a think
about it and how it relates to this that
is exactly the same as X percent of pain
we can switch the numbers right let me
give you an example let's try 72 percent
of 50 now I don't know about you but 72
percent that's not a nice and I can't
think of an equivalent fraction that
nicely hits that 72 times 5 the
significant figures are still quiet like
my brain sort of can't handle those but
because multiplication this is really 72
percent times 50 right because
multiplication is commutative you can
actually swap these numbers over and get
something nice and easy it's the same as
50 percent that's my Pro numeral P of 72
do you see I'm swapping them ok we know
what 50 percent is right it's a nice
equivalent fraction what's it equal to
we actually said it before it's a half
right because someone tell me what half
is Sony 2 is
it's 3636
which if you like you can go to your
calculator and you can verify if you
punched in 72 percent times 50 you would
get 36 as well so here are these three
really handy techniques that you can use
mentally to not have to require you to
get a calculator out all right